Fran Fraschilla joining us now on the
ESPN and Westwood one college basketball
analyst you can help me out with this a
little bit friend is that everything has
been about Zion Zion Zion and Duke and
you know a couple of the guys here and
there but what other players should we
be watching during this tournament as it
kicks off tomorrow in the field of 64
oh yeah there'll be there'll be guys
that come out of nowhere and our heroes
Kirk you know off the bat if Wofford is
one of those Cinderella stories you got
to look at Twitter McGee young man who
is two three-pointers away from tying
the all-time record he's close to 500
three-point shots and obviously
Wofford's had a great season only four
losses all four losses too high major
team so that's a guy to keep in mind I
just got done watching Iowa State win
the big 12 title right and how about
Marial shayok the transfer from Virginia
120 point game in his first 101 games at
Virginia this year he plays at Iowa
State and he has 14 20-point games and
second leading scorer in the big 12
those are two guys that immediately jump
out at me you know they're that this
it's one of those deals where every year
we we find new heroes because this
tournament has always been about this
basketball reality TV you know friend
what gets everybody's attention is when
the sirens go off and that means it's
upset alert who should be on upset alert
when you look at this the opening round
games well you know what we just saw all
Byrne played great in the SEC Tournament
winning winning the tournament title
obviously and they really put things
together over the over that week but you
know all of a sudden they're gonna see a
New Mexico State team that's 30 and for
play like a bunch of junkyard dogs and
you know we know about Buffalo we kind
of know about Murray State John Brant
and obviously Nevada out west but that's
it that's a team that comes to mind I
would not sleep on Utah State excuse me
I think I think Utah state's got a very
very dangerous team they gave
they'll beat Nevada two out of three
times played great in their Mountain
West tournament and they've got a really
good balance of great outside shooting
and a terrific freshman big man from
Portugal Keita I believe who you know
could become a name so you know if
you're playing Utah State I think you
got to be concerned and uh you know a
team that I really like and it's not an
upset but in the eight nine game I see a
team like Central Florida how cool how
cool would it be if Johnny Dawkins
esteemed Beach VCU and then sees you
know Duke in the next round his mentor
and Johnny is probably the most
important player in Duke history many
have made that argument because he was
the guy that turned Coach K's Duke
program around in the mid 80s
he's friend for Shelley ESPN in Westwood
one college basketball analyst joining
the Rich Eisen show Kirk Morrison
filling in for Rich obviously and you
look at the for number one seats someone
doesn't fit right I mean they're not in
the ACC so I guess Gonzaga they're the
team that's the odd man out in terms of
they didn't even win their conference
tournament yet they still got the number
one seed we understand that play well
all season long but how do we view
Gonzaga as compared to the three ACC
team to got number one seeds well you
know what it's really interesting I
would have said prior to the loss of st.
Mary's that Gonzaga you know if you put
Kentucky and you put Duke in the WCC
that they would not have rolled through
those leagues any differently than
Gonzaga did I mean they would have won
by an average of 28 points a game as
well
now Gonzaga comes in with a little you
know scratch on the armor here because
of that inexplicable loss the Saint
Mary's in the in the WCC final and and
so I still love them I Kurt but here's
the problem I also love Florida State
and I think what Leonard Hamilton has
done this year with this team twenty
seven and seven meeting Duke in the you
know in the ACC final they have
essentially the same team back that went
to the Elite Eight last year and so
while I really like Gonzaga and I
definitely think they're capable of
winning the national championship I've
got Florida State advancing past both
Gonzaga and Michigan in my bracket
because I believe
in Leonard Hamilton team's athleticism
their depth their size inside so I
that's a tough matchup out west looking
jacket no friend I need you I need your
expertise on this one because you can
take me behind a curtain a little bit
because you've coached in these NCAA
Tournament games you've been to the
postseason you understand what it takes
in order to succeed so how do you handle
the emotions of the players you know
this is a big stage for a lot of guys
and yeah you know obviously you're going
to have to make adjustments you're gonna
have to make some changes how do you do
that in a game in which you don't hate
if we don't play well we're out there is
no game after that how do you make those
changes you know throughout a basketball
game well it's a great it's a great
question Kurt I think first of all you
got to stay positive and you got to be
upbeat and you got to celebrate your
season you know I actually lost the
tournament came in 1998 when st. John's
lost at Detroit because I had my team
too much on edge you know I didn't want
us to lose the lose the edge we had you
know with playing in the Big East the
whole season and that was the wrong
approach now I have had other teams like
Manhattan upset and Oklahoma for 13 game
so here's my answer
number one celebrate the success
selections Hyundai and the 12 hours
after that you know enjoy the accolades
the press conferences the media
spotlight that you're under and then you
get back to business and you have to
prepare the NCAA tournament you only you
only going to play two games in one
weekend and you don't know who you're
playing in the second game right so you
treat it like you were playing in an
in-season 14 tournament and you have to
keep everything as routine as possible
the kids know it's a big deal but you
have to be relaxed and that's you know
that's really important they have to see
you're relaxed that you're prepared and
that we're treating this next game like
any other game that we prepare for on
the schedule and you know keep them keep
them as normal as possible Fran
Fraschilla ESPN at Westwood one college
basketball analyst joining us here on
the Rich Eisen show Kirk Morrison
filling in for rich just a couple more
minutes with you Fran you first went to
the tournament 1993
and now in 2019 what do you think has
been the biggest difference when you
look at the tournament from when you
first appeared as a coach to where the
tournament is now well it's amazing well
I I didn't even remember my first you
know years as a young coach I can
remember in 1982-83 as an assistant at
Ohio you go into the tournament 48 teams
you played in you you you know you've
got 33 through 48 played into the
tournament I'm not sure how they did it
but I know that 164 it's just so much
bigger you know it really is I mean it's
it's it's obvious to see that that you
know whether it's CBS and Turner and and
the way the tournament is now televised
and the exposure and throws social media
into that throw the the hype that we
create throughout the season uh you know
Zion playing in his first and only NCAA
Tournament it's just uh you know it's
all-encompassing they call it March
Madness for a reason it used to be just
simply the bat and NCAA basketball
championship right but I think I'd have
to take you back to what I said earlier
in the conversation we have created must
watch reality TV in March and early
April because none of us knows what's
going to happen you know do you expect
the unexpected Dean finally beat one
somebody hits a 50-footer at the buzzer
to you know knock somebody else out
celebrations running around the court
buzzer beaters heartbreak kids crying
it's what I love about the tournament
and it's become so big and it's become
that's why it's become such a part of
American sports hey friend I know I
gotta let you go I got 30 seconds real
quick I know you got Florida State
coming out of the West but when you look
at the South in the Midwest I personally
got Tennessee out of the south North
Carolina out of the Midwest how do you
see the south and the Midwest kind of
shaken up well I love Tennessee and I
work I work for Rick Barnes and at
Providence you know I've got enormous
respect for Tennessee I I just I got a
sneaky suspicion that Virginia is the
best team in the tournament um it wants
to do twice I get it and I wouldn't
shock me if Tennessee gets the final
four but i real
like Virginia and on the other side
Kentucky beat North Carolina by 10 on a
neutral court in December I think this
is a better North Carolina team I like I
like North Carolina coming out of that
region as well I'm excited to watch you
sin play obviously you know I've got a
little investment in Villanova they've
had a great year they can get to the
sweet 16 but for me on that side of the
bracket which I see Virginia North
Carolina and you don't want Curt I think
there's only been one time in NCAA
history if I'm not mistaken that three
teams from the same conference got to a
Final Four and that would have been 85
so it's possible the way this is set up
that we could see at least two ACC teams
maybe three and how crazy would it
beautiful sophomore yeah so I guess
you're saying Duke out of the East and I
got it frame preciate it
hey Fran thanks for the time I know you
got a lot going on closing the door I'm
headed to New York for Westwood sounds
good thanks for appreciate it as Fran
Fraschilla ESPN and Westwood One the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience